Robert what's your advice for a
first-time writer director for
first-time writer director you mean both
or or separately both like you know
somebody that's either in a career
that's flourishing as you were in or
even something that's alright it's a
simple answer don't take it all so
seriously number one for first time
right you know when you're ready for
writers I would say think about actors
when you're writing it's really
important if you want to be a spec
writer and sell scripts Williams Goldman
said it better than I ever could stars
get movies made so think about actors
even if it's not if you're not gonna be
a big spec writer but yeah think about
actors when you're writing and and just
don't think it also seriously as a
director
you